Você sabia que mesmo com décadas de
alertas, quase ninguém no mundo está
consumindo ômega-3 suficiente? Pois é,
uma revisão da Universidade de Cambridge
acabou de confirmar isso. Os
pesquisadores reuniram diretrizes de
vários países e descobriram que a
maioria das populações não consegue
atingir nem o mínimo recomendado que
fica entre 250 e 500 mg por dia de EPA e
DHA. O problema é que a principal fonte
são peixes gordurosos, como salmão,
sardinha, cavala. E olha só, pouca gente
come isso regularmente, seja por custo,
seja por gosto mesmo. E por que que isso
importa tanto? Veja bem, o ômega-3 não é
frescura, ele é essencial para proteger
o coração, manter o cérebro funcionando
bem e controlar inflamações no corpo
inteiro. Quando falta o risco de
problemas cardiovasculares, aumenta, a
memória pode falhar e aquela inflamação
silenciosa que envelhece suas células
fica solta. Então fica a reflexão. Você
sabe quanto-3 está consumindo por dia?
Se não come peixe gordo pelo menos duas
vezes por semana, valear uma
suplementação de qualidade.